welcome back to new rock stars and just
because the scarlet witch destroyed all
the copies of the dark hole in
multiverse madness you probably thought
it was safe to read a book at your local
library didn't you
think again alphabet nerds because the
dark hole multiverse and madness is
still out there in the mcu and i don't
have to worry about it because you know
despite 30 years of trying i still can't
read this is rogue theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is mt
and going world with me today is the
queen of dreams herself it's jessica
clemens what's going on jess that's a
nice way of saying freddy krueger's wife
but yes
pretty good hell yeah
i went to every child's wedding it was
beautiful
and it's the scarlet witch of the owl
house herself it's the one and only
whitney van laningham what's going on
yeah that's the best thing that's my
best intro that's the best thing you've
ever said about me thank you thank you
thank you hi
it's me i'm here i haven't been on this
show in so long i'm so excited to see
you seriously
i missed you too and of course we cannot
forget about our special guest the chaos
king in the flesh it's my boy eddie
villanueva what's going on are you
what is up my fellow nerds how you guys
doing i'm excited to be here as well
it's been a minute with us just like
whitney said so i'm excited just to dive
right in hey and eddie is from the films
lost the first podcast by the way you
guys check that out like
um all right guys multiverse of madness
also known as what mouth the movie is
now out in glorious hd on disney plus so
we can all watch reed richards turn into
toilet paper together but re-watching
multiverse abandons made me realize
something crazy about the dark hole
y'all which leads us to our first topic
of today the darkhold is still
very much a threat to the mcu multiverse
and here's why i think so because if you
remember at the end of multiverse of
madness yes wanda destroys all the
copies of the darkhold throughout the
multiverse however we do
only see her destroy the one mount to
undergo in earth 616 which means that
mount wondergore still exists in other
universes in the multiverse and as we
know from multiverse of madness mount
wondergore in the actual the temple
there at mo at the top of mount moondrug
is where the dark hold was copied like
that's where the darkhold was written
off the walls of mount wondergore so if
mount wonder gore still exists in the
multiverse that means someone can make a
new dark hold to uh ruin people's lives
with so what do you guys think
uh i feel like there's
always a possibility i mean we look at
the marvel universe as a whole and we
have i mean obviously this running joke
nobody ever stays dead except for uncle
ben um it seems like
the idea of
something strong and something as
powerful of an entity as the darkhold
actually going away is
non-existent in our minds i mean really
you have somebody who has the power of
the eye of agamotto who can literally
turn his hand like this like he's
turning the dial on the thermostat and
pretty much return an apple to its
original form or make it wither so if he
can do that with that kind of object
which is an organic object why couldn't
he do it with a book and maybe not him
per se
but if somebody else had hold of the eye
of agamotto or a power similar to
they could essentially be nefarious and
you know
turn back the dial on uh you know the
dark world and create a whole new dark
hole altogether it's just so true like
there is a way for like the 616 universe
even to get their dark hole back but you
know what the time stone is gone
so like the time zone's not really a
factor anymore so like i guess that like
is a great thing for for the dark cold
coming back but like still it it could
still happen like in in like the dark i
feel like the time still could come back
in in any form well we just know that
the time is gone in london there's
apparently just like a whole drawer full
of them just laying around somewhere so
i think that the infinity stones totally
have the potential to come back some but
i don't think
scarlet witch i think scarlet witch got
rid of it in every universe versus the
stones that she couldn't get rid of
and all or they shouldn't care about
um i think the only way that they could
come back is if the demon comes back
um and the demon rewrites his things on
a wall
um yeah i think it's going to be really
hard for i always said shaythan so
it's like i do too and then i did a
video and i said it and everybody made
fun of me and i was like sorry it's a
[Music]
it's a fake demon person i'm sorry i
pronounced i'm sorry for offending you
shaythan
i don't whatever you because i can't say
van laningham right so you know just eat
my hats man there you go
i i agree with you
i feel like i feel like jess is on to
something in terms of because from what
we do see in the film the implication is
that every book has been destroyed but
we don't know if every time stone was
used as part of that end game you know
strategy for
you know the events with thanos so there
could be a ton of time stones still
existing in other universes kind of like
what whitney said in loki there's a
whole drawer full of them i mean you
know you could do one of those little
you know bedazzling on a vest you know
another thor vest and kind of thing with
the stones but there's always an
opportunity so there's always an option
imagine if you're drunk your uh your
junk drawer was just filled with
infinity stones instead of like random
pencils from the fourth grade that are
worn down to the nub and paper clips and
maybe a spray uh cassette tape you're
like that's what my junk drawer is i
wish my junk drawer was infinite
cosmic weaponry no big deal like things
that could end the universe yeah mine is
like stickers and sewing supplies like
way lamer way lamer
that's uh i feel like that's how thanos
was just storing the infinity stone
before you destroyed them he's like all
right all done gotta put in my drawer
with the rest of my loose stuff with my
farm
loose items
he was he was just sitting his room he
goes
you know what guys
we could put these on a glove
[Laughter]
i think i could put these on a glove
like i think i could go to the met gala
with this i think this would be i think
i could like he took too many edibles
and couldn't stop looking at his own
hands and he was like
i think i've just covered something he's
like guys the [ __ ] ringing idea is out
we're going with the glove let's
[Laughter]
it's been a go different end game in
infinity war i tell you that much hey
man it gives you a different meaning to
the word end game if you know what i
mean
but no um so yeah back to the topic
about this dark hole still existing in
the mcu so like what do you guys think
if this is true could be like the
possible implications like who else do
you think could be tempted by the dark
hold if it still exists well first of
all i had a theory a while back that i
did a video on i think that wanda is
still alive i don't think that she died
in the collapse of mountain de gore i
think that she
somehow survived i think that her magic
protected her whether she wanted it to
or not and i think that that was like
what that like scarlet plume that we saw
in the explosion was i think that that
was actually her magic protecting her
not her like dying and exploding in a
little red cloud i mean she could have
but i this is rogue theory [ __ ] i'm
yeah
i think that she's still i think she's
still alive and i think that at some
point what i would love to see and it
might not happen but whatever i think it
would be so cool to see
like another wanda from another universe
getting the darkhold back through her
mount wondergore and then r wanda is
like displaced doesn't like has no
memory of who she is doesn't even know
what happened you know
head empty no thoughts just just her
beautiful face
yeah me too you know just like just like
that empty no thoughts um
so i think that it'd be really cool
to have to see wanda like
get her memories back get her mojo back
and then
fight another wanda from making the same
mistakes i'd see that short film like
all the other ones yeah how wanda got
her groove back
yeah
yeah i totally see that i would love
that that would be dope but also no i
feel like that scenario could
potentially happen because we know that
eight three eight wanda had her life
ruined by six years six wanda yeah
everyone in the universe or at least
everyone on earth hates wanda right now
from that universe so and her wonder war
still exists
technically so i feel like we could see
a scenario where this wand is like i
have nowhere else to go everyone hates
me i'm gonna go up climb out this
mountain and learn something new and
we can have another multiverse of
madness i'm going to take a little hike
and learn some new things oh no it's
demonology
oh no i'm possessed
ah [ __ ] not again how
um
but yeah so i guess it's time for the
ultimate judgment on my theory now i
need you guys to vote whether or not you
think this this idea this this wild
theory this rogue theory of the dark
hole being rewritten again from the very
walls of mount wondergore's in different
realities what do you guys think of it
in general let's starting with
jessica clemens
hmm
i don't think it's rogus but i also
don't think it's bogus
it's just in the middle empty i want you
to start serving me piping hot
rogue theories
it's like the goldilocks and the three
bears
it's not joke it's not right
except for it's not well you go is it
not real
bogus is it just ogus
it's
we came up with something in the middle
for it last time but i can't remember it
was this you did this well this but we
called it yeah because i was like
oh it's ogus
i think it's great i think it's a good
theory i just don't think it's crazy but
i do think it's a good theory okay
that's a good point that's a good point
oh guess it is one ogus from one jessica
clemens
next up we have eddie what do you think
eddie um i i have to agree with jessica
i feel like it's a good theory i feel
like there's
obvious merit to it like we said the
whole uncle ben scenario the the way
mwanda is obviously not fully gone uh
because i mean let's be honest can we
really get rid of elizabeth olsen right
now um and too much power and to be
quite frank she's our harley quinn which
is unfortunate she is i need her to die
yeah
um i i feel like it it's it's got a lot
of merit to it so i'll give it a nogus
as well i i feel like it's not
roguish enough to be
out there and outlandish but it is
decent enough to have merit for it to be
pretty much probably already in feige's
plan eddie eddie said he needs to buy
outlandish if he's gonna approve of it
it needs to be
he's got it i'm sorry sorry i mean i i
need i need some like idle hand kind of
you know homage where it's actually you
know captain america's ass that had been
chopped off and
dark himself you know because of the
fact of through powers because wanda
loved captain america somehow
we have different levels of what rogue
theory means to us
is
just pornography
uh partially yeah yeah okay
yeah i would love to see um ass of m um
just uh the steve the reality where
steven
um makes
she would just carve the symbols in his
ass cheeks have you seen that episode of
family guy where they're in prison and
the guy
he's like can you autograph my butt and
he's like sure and he uses a shank to do
it that's what it would be it would be
horrible oh my god and it's not like
marvel isn't going in that direction i
mean you guys remember the last thor
trailer where
you flick too hard damn it you know that
i mean we're about to get you know the
the front and the back possibly so i
mean i just i'm just saying hey it's not
like marvel's not going that way anyway
i'm just i'm just rolling with the tide
hey man they already once they put those
two game of thrones actors and eternals
and all beds were off
my friends yeah we need more dick in the
mcu we're getting full nudity oh it's
gonna be great we're full friends i
don't think they're good at it because
that sex scene and eternals was
atrocious it was the worst thing i've
ever done it was it wasn't pretty
amazing
it was
it was like a straight to tv movie kind
of sex scene one of those ones where
it's just like uh top of the head bottom
of the feet they're making noises and
then boom it's done
yeah exactly it would be hilarious if
like they all they all had bodies of
like barbie dolls so like because like
they're android so it's like they're
they're pretending to have sex but like
they don't have
to do like so like team america world
police you're talking about that sex
scene basic
they're two puppets just
yes just slapping together it's like hey
this is how we can keep it pg-13
um but anyway whitney what do you think
i've got two opuses i'll take those
oguses
you know i think it's rogues as hell
i like it because i agree because i
think that i
think that we're gonna see wanda come
back because i strongly believe that the
house of m storyline is gonna come into
play somehow
and i think that if wanda comes back
wounded gore's coming back baby wanda
wundergore whitney let's go wanda winter
whitney www
i don't know what i'm saying
thank you i'll take that rogus with
happiness so i would say two ogus's
equals one rogues i think it's like
i think two yeah i don't think two
negatives make a positive but go off go
off
go off feel free okay
okay it is one rocus and two ogus's i
will take that but up next jess is going
to pitch a wild mystery theory about the
train in miss marvel but first we want
to thank upstart for sponsoring this
episode of rogue theory because it can
be hard to see the light at the end of
the tunnel when you have high interest
debt and also if you have terrible eyes
like me and sometimes it can be even
harder to ask for help and that's where
upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom so whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than dishes credit score upstart's
model considers other factors like your
income employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
and you can check your rate within
minutes for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars without
impacting your credit score you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so do not
wait and check your rate today over at
upstart.com rogue theory that is
upstart.com rogue theory to check your
rate today and do not forget to use our
url to let them know that we sent you or
else they will not know loan amounts
will determine based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com rogue theory you also want
to express thanks for expressvpn my god
they're so good watching netflix without
using expressvpn it's like having an
array of superpowers and only being able
to use one of them why would you limit
yourself like that
that's stupid that's the dumbest thing
in the world tap into that unlimited
power people because netflix has
different libraries of content for every
country but without a vpn you can only
see a fraction of their content based on
your location that's whack expressvpn
lets you change your online location you
can control where you want netflix or
other streaming websites to think you're
located several members of the new
restaurant staff loved using expressvpn
our screen producer brandon was able to
catch up on better call saul before it
was available on us netflix because
brandon is a smart man who knows how to
get things done the efficient way we
love expressvpn for its blazing fast
speeds that enable you to stream in hd
without buffering and the fact that it
works with tons of streaming services
like bbc iplayer youtube and more it's
even more amazing so be smart stop
paying full price for streaming services
and only getting access to a fraction of
their content that's ridiculous come on
love yourself get your money's worth
over at expressvpn.com
and don't forget to use my link at
expressvpn.com to get extra three months
of expressvpn for free lately i've been
listening to a lot of true crime
podcasts and it's been great you know
aside from all the murder but one reason
it's been great to listen to you it's
because i use my raycon wireless earbuds
to do it raycon's everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fits these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me i have the widest ear holes in
the world and uh they just won't fall
out of my ear holes it's amazing raycons
offer three sound profiles to match what
you're listening to plus noise isolation
and awareness mode so you can choose to
be immersed in sound or be able to hear
your surroundings when you need to which
is very important i like to use my
raycon to listen to podcasts while i'm
doing dumb boring chores around the
house they're great because they never
fall out no matter how much i move
around and some of my chores involve me
fighting lots of crime in my
neighborhood so like i need to be able
to
punch without the earbuds falling out
you understand raycons give you eight
hours of play time and 32 hour battery
life then when you need to charge it's
super easy you can even do it wirelessly
because we're in the future with raycons
you get the same quality audio as other
premium audio brands but at half the
price amazing and they're built to last
so you don't have to worry about using
them too much it's no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 49 000
five-star reviews check out raycon's
wireless earbuds my guess is that you're
going to want to leave them a five-star
review as well go to buyrecon.com rogue
theory today to get 15 off your reikon
order that's by raycon dot com slash
rogue theory to score fifteen percent
off by recon dot com slash rogue theory
all right just take it away yeah i got
you so my theory isn't as crazy i don't
think but maybe it is let's see let's
dive into it essentially i think that
the train station of karachi is where
the veil meets earth and aisha stayed
back to fight off the other clandestines
and died
um in the process so if you watch the
episode this is all about episode four
of ms marvel so if you haven't watched
episode four by now i'm going to spoil
it all for you and i don't care right
you had you had like six days by the
time this video comes out to have seen
it by now so i'm gonna tell you about it
so this is i'll give you a list of the
reasons why i think this is possible so
number one in episode one we thought or
at least i thought what was the watchers
when she jumps back down into that uh
the what we thought was like um
the spiritual any kind of rome uh we
thought those might have been the
watchers or at least i did i pitched
that very hard and i now know that that
is not because those are definitely the
people dip boarding different trains
during the partition
um and but i don't blame you for
thinking they were watchers they looked
very we were all like oh because the i
don't know i listen to boston there's
there's there's there's throwing eyes
there's the eyes there's the eyes and
eric boss so
do not come to me so i think that uh
it's clearly the people boarding
different trains going to different
places during the partition and i think
that crack that we see her go through
were like oh it's her just dipping into
it no i think that crack symbolizes the
veil that's between um where the trains
were departing and the actual nor and i
also think she didn't just dip into like
an idea she actually went into the past
again that was just a little taste we
got in the first episode and we get it
fully in the fourth episode at the very
end number two kamala's father said that
sana's mom just disappeared that night
and cameron's mom said that she got lost
that night like the rest of them during
the partition and that's another hint to
why i think that's the veil that little
veil is cracked and that's why people
that are clandestines are able to get in
and out of there as long as they have
the bangle they also said that the
bengal is fully used by kamala because
she has the humanity of the earth and i
think that's why the clandestines can't
use the bengal but they can use it if
they go to the train station of karachi
because that's where there's a crack in
the veil so it's simpler for them to get
back into nor if they get that one
single bangle and can just sneak through
that crack second thirdly thirdly i'm
sorry
what you seek is seeking you as what is
said you're preaching for it it was what
is inscribed on the as inscribed on the
bengal and i think that is clearly
because it's the key to noir so it's
like while you seek north nor seeking
you because nor want you to come back
because that is a piece of the nor
technology and the light
fourthly i think aisha recognized that
earth was actually a lot better than
what it was she has a daughter she has a
husband and i think the other ones
cameron's mom the evil clandestines are
like no this earth sucks look at what
they're doing to each other they're
literally murdering each other we need
to take it over and just
redo everything that's why we need to
release the veil and i think she was
aisha was on board at that at first and
then she realized that that was not the
way to go and kind of in a god-like
moment i think she realized like i need
to protect these people from my own
people and that's how the veil became
and then that's how she didn't die
essentially she got to go back because
if they were all exiled she got to go
back to nora because nora was like you
recognize that these are people there's
humanity in them that's why like uh
kamala can use the full power because
she has the humanity of earth still with
her and the other clandestines that are
evil are still exiled and they don't and
that's why they think the red dagger
society or whatever think that they're
only there to destroy the earth and it's
like no they're not we only know from
the ones that got exiled we don't know
from the other clandestines that are
still in nor who are that probably just
think earth's a great place and we
shouldn't be destroying it so i think
that train station that she keeps seeing
and her aunt and her great grandmother
that she keeps seeing is actually the
veil that's cracking and she can see
that veil and that's the closest that
her grandma great grandma can get to her
but i think that train station
specifically is the border that is
cracked separating noir from
uh earth
boom love this theory i think it's so
great because like like there's
something special about this train
station there's something about the
train itself that has to do with the
veil so i feel like i would love for the
for the veil to actually be at this
train station and it was super symbolic
because of the whole partition thing too
so yeah
that and i think there's a reason they
brought up thor in episode four i think
they're gonna bring it up again by being
like the veil or whatever is there but
it's like uh it's the train station is a
big part because it's the people it's
the clandestine people as well because
the she was like a lot of us got lost
that day and it's like yeah because you
guys are just like us in a way just how
like a new asgard it was like it's not
the place it's the people and i think
that's the same symbolism that goes with
this it's like it's not that you guys
are separated into two now it's that you
guys are still people to be fair i am
not pakistani i'm not india like i don't
have the right to say like any of like
we are all the same people because i did
not live that history that is not my
culture
but i just think if there is a message
that they're trying to bring across it's
that like
even the clandestines were there too
like there was a lot it was bigger than
a lot of people but it was destroying a
big place um okay
what do you mean you're not pakistani i
i just assumed this entire time i'm
brown just like you but just from a
different fondant
i mean i'm brown
i feel like there's a lot of merit to
this to this uh theory
mostly
because obviously number one it's just
but also because of the fact that um
i mean they've been giving hints
throughout the entire series
the noir is essentially just
a
tangible
form of the quantum universe i mean
honestly the quantum realm so what we're
looking at here is essentially a way to
punch through into the quantum realm and
if there's people already on one side of
it who have the ability to
you know
wield whatever to make it through that
or if there was a crack somewhere i mean
who's to say you know that uh this isn't
something that is
definitively in a place because of a
people you know we've seen things where
like situations happen or places are
unique because of what happened there i
mean look at sokovia you know so you
have all these different elements of
because of the importance of the place
and the amount of i guess
you know energy
invested
into that place that could be almost
like a like a gateway right there and
then like jess said so i think i think
there's a lot of merit to this yeah i
like it i think they're that that and
there is so many like little hints to it
there and obviously this is
eric boss's brain this is mt's brain
this is like whitney's brain anyone that
does a breakdown brain of like pulling
every little bit of information that
probably isn't connected they just put
it in the show but
they
put literally everything they kept being
like um there's a gate that you have to
go through there's uh they were like
hyster when you look at the sign that
was like don't go beyond this part
because we're trying to restore the
beauty of the history and like there
were there's so many nods where i was
like okay we get it there's something
mystical beyond that part that we
haven't seen yet
is
there is that and then clearly when i
was like thinking of this theory i then
was like
uh oh oh so the fact that when she
stabbed her bangle i think that was nor
weapon nor weaponry so the nor weaponry
with the actual bengal coming in contact
made her go into the action pass whereas
when she did in the first episode she
was only using the power of the bengal
uh but i also realized after episode
four happened i was like oh so kamala's
the stars that led her grandma back to
her gran her great-grandfather because i
think she has her look i was literally
waiting until my turn to say that but
my no no it's okay it's okay uh my my
theory on that is that
i agree with you
i think that
she is now
back in the past and i i really think
that it's gonna be like a harry potter
patronus situation
where
uh her great-grandma does get sucked
back through that crack into the nor and
then nobody's there to help her grandma
get onto the train and so she has to do
it and so i think that the stars that
came out of nowhere were always from
kamala which
i think that's gonna also lead to a very
like emotional scene where she actually
ends up meeting her great grandma and in
the course of like battling and trying
to protect her family she tells her you
know protect your you know protect my
daughter as she gets slipped away
through the nor and she has to do the
building of the stars
i think the grandma knows
i think the grandma knows and that's why
she kept being like have you found what
you're looking for and it was like no
and it was like the train i saw the
train you have to come back to karachi
and go see the train i think the grandma
absolutely knows that her ni her
granddaughter is the stars but she's not
saying anything and she's so great i
would love if she knew and she was like
i can't really
because when they were having their
conversation in the room i was like the
grandma knows a lot but doesn't know a
lot but i think she does know a lot
she's just not telling her she's like
you need to figure it out on your own oh
yeah and we love those guys
ben kenobi yeah
and then she's like it was me the whole
time i had the higher ground um
it was me yeah that's
um it was me all the time
i love like everything that you guys are
saying right now because like we're
going back to eddie real quick like i
love how you mentioned that like uh the
quantum realm could be involved in
quantum energy because like when she
goes back in time we do see like this
like yellow glow like
the yellow cracks that are sort of look
like quantum energy if you look back to
in ant-man the wasp
we see um
always makes their names up janet van
dyne and she uses the her quantum energy
to heal ghosts and like it's a very
similar color there so like yeah i think
that we could be seeing like maybe when
we get the second bagel maybe that could
be like a quantum energy type of bangle
that like using them together could
allow kamala to go back in time anytime
she wants that'd be really fun um and
what jess said about like the two um the
dagger from another universe like
hitting the the bengal which i'm
assuming is from this universe
i think like they're the something that
could have happened between like the two
different types of matter interacting
with each other it's like we are not
supposed to be touching each other so
like yeah a crack of reality is going to
happen
it could have eventually been or could
have essentially been aisha's weapon
that she reforged into a bengal so that
way like if she gave up violence to have
a family here in this realm or in this
universe you know she could have very
well you know reforged it or changed it
however her abilities can and turned it
into a bengal that would you know
harness the power of noir much like her
weapons because everybody's weapon seems
to be like defy the laws of physics you
know and whatnot and you know so we know
that these aren't like
local weapons uh so
she may very well have turned hers into
that bengal and that's what that bangle
is oh i like i have two things right
that i was like yes yeah also okay so
first off i i i agree with you if that
is aisha's tool i think that that girl
um cameron's mom actually did kill her
uh during the partition and maybe in the
flashback kamala might be able to see
that but if she didn't i agree with
whitney when she says that she gets
zipped back into the nor i think i think
she struggled she was like my daughter
my baby my husband like what the hell
and her freakout is the thing that
caused the the veil to crack and so it's
like a full circle moment where maybe
the only person that can re make that
happen is kamala um which is will be a
sad moment because it'll be like her
great grandma on the other side her on
the other side and she's closing that
door like in um and turning red where
she's looking in the mirror and it's
like you can stay a panda or you cannot
like the rest of us and she it closes
um so i think that would be an emotional
scene that we might be able to see i
hope we see oh yeah i would love like
that i love turning red a lot so like i
love that comparison it's really good
was so good um so good such a good movie
you know the episode for this is called
turning red by the way yeah it is that
is literally the title of this episode
that's so funny yeah well like see was
it cigarette turner i don't know i think
it's oh this one's about the soup that
one's about the panda
um
because we white wash chinese soup and
that's why it's red now or it's not red
anymore um
we do a lot of bad things that's mh it's
true it's very true um but no i love all
these theories like all the like
especially all these um
additions to justice theory but we have
to now
give her the ultimate judgment is
justice theory rogus or bogus let's
start with whitney van lenningham rogus
as hell baby our heart is yeah
hell yeah
i think i do i really think that she's
gonna end up being the stars that's like
the first thing i thought when i watched
that episode i was like it's gonna be
her and she's gonna save her own grandma
right
can you imagine if she if she just
decides not to save the child and then
she just disappears oh yeah just like
she just disappears
back to the future yeah
it's like you're not captain marvel get
out of my face
it's your grandma marty your grandma
yeah your grandma marty we gotta do
something grandma
it's about your grandma
but eddie what do you think i i think
it's it's it's pretty rogues i feel like
this is one of those elements that i
feel has been building up towards and if
you're somebody who's not very savvy in
the mcu
you know universe and all the mechanics
and everything they've been introducing
i feel like the fact that this is
ultimately the quantum realm and this is
a fixed point if you will because we've
talked about fixed points before in the
mcu so i feel like this place this time
this moment is a fixed point
and uh we're just gonna it's just all
going to
solidify the foundation that's already
been created and all the other shows and
whatnot and this is this is a great uh
theory into making that a reality so
rogus
yes of course jess is like the queen of
rogue theories man i gotta say um
because i also agree with both of you
guys because
yeah like i i just wanna i really want
to see that final battle at this train
station i feel like there's something
really special about this train station
throughout the entire series and like to
for the veil to open up there and like
because like the whole symbolism of a
train being able to
transport you from a to b i just feel
like this makes a lot of sense so like
yeah and like i just i just really want
to see some weird time travel [ __ ]
happen with this train station i just
want this train station to be the focal
the true focal point of the show by
having the bail be there so i'm going to
say rogus as well making just the triple
rogues queen of the day oh my gosh
look at justin go triple rogers
[Music]
she's
queen
now we're getting into lord of the rings
but this now leads us to our rogue
question of the day are you guys ready
[Music]
hooray because we all know that kamala
khan is a massive super fan of captain
marvel and with many expecting brie
larson herself to make an appearance as
carol damores at some point during the
show tell us your rogues idea for how
the scene could go down i pitched this
before
i pitched before not in rogue theory on
the break room where i think it's going
to be at the very end
very very end what's going to happen is
monica photon junior is going to show up
and is going to be like i can help you
with your powers because
i am photon i can do it monica's here on
earth
and then carol danvers is gonna jump in
and be like you're the one using my name
and taking my powers and that's gonna
set us up for the marvels where they're
gonna be fighting to train kamala but
kamala doesn't need to be trained
anymore she's already great but she's
gonna bring them back together uh monica
and carol danvers because right now
monica hates that [ __ ] so it's true
another break room theory of mine i
think carol danvers gave her mom cancer
uh
but that is for another day i honestly
have a feeling well as well i think
that's a very valid theory i think they
went together too many different places
and she got sick and she did it because
she's an alien human now
either way
that would be a really great reason for
why carol denver's like doesn't want to
be around earth because earthlings
probably can't handle her radiation
she's probably like a like sort of like
the whole like dark dr manhattan thing
in that watch yes
you know people thought that he was a
radioactive threat to people so like
yeah that'd be i love that idea yeah i
mean it would be very sad but yes um
yeah like that's a really great idea i
love it but yes um what what do you guys
think what do you what do you got
whitney
so i think that it's possible that ms
marvel's going to come back
um because i think that the bengal might
be cree technology
that like came to our planet um the
theory that i had like a week or
something ago was
that it's possible that the cree came to
our planet when they were escaping like
the cree skull war skrull war not skull
war yeah that'd be cool
as hell the skull war uh
war we're we're hitting people with
skulls they're not even ours they're not
even ourselves we're just going to get
them um
uh the kree scroll war if they were like
escaping or running from that i think
that it could have been
like possibly around the same time that
the meteorite landed in wakanda and gave
the earth vibranium i think that it's
possible that the creek came at some
point and this is possibly uh leftover
cree weaponry um and so i and i think
that that might be where like the
missing bangle went like perhaps like
they said it could have either been
looted from the tomb already or maybe it
was
given to somebody else buried somewhere
else whatever and so i think that ms
marvel is going to come to earth to
check it out and be like oh captain
marvel free tech being used captain
marvel yeah i was sorry what did i say
ms marvel he said miss marvel whoops i
think
oh sorry captain marvel's gonna come
back to talk to miss marvel because
she's going to be like yo i think you
got a creep angle there baby girl you
want to uh
let me know what's going on and then
they're going to like work together
that's what i think oh
interesting that's going to be the
bangle that can happen
that makes sense yeah it's going to be
the bangle that brings it that's that's
actually smart that's actually cool my
theory is this
because we haven't seen a follow-up from
the damage control folks
uh i feel like the way
this is going to happen is in the end
than the last episode we're gonna see
damage control finally catch up with
miss marvel
take her
question her and everything and
as like it seems like she's gonna be
going away for a while
we're actually gonna see a actual
government official come in
otherwise known as roadie
say guys i'm taking care of this one let
me go ahead and i'll handle her she's
coming with me
takes her they walk all the way out of
the complex and she goes well why how
come you how do you even know about who
i am how do you blah blah he goes well
my girlfriend actually wants to talk to
you and then boom captain or captain
marvel's like
i'm just my girlfriend chauffeur
yeah exactly
because i mean we all know that's that's
that's possibly going to happen sometime
soon i mean
shipping you know rhodes and rhodey and
uh captain marvel and from the comics
and everything else so yeah right and
they sort of hinted at a relationship
and uh end game i feel like end game
sort of like be careful honey it's like
okay boo boo um so yeah i would love to
see rhodey and captain marvel be
introduced in that way that would be
really fun um because like
i feel like we do like you're right like
dodc is going to arrest miss marvel at
some point we're going to see agent
cleary question the the person that he's
been looking for and i think that it'd
be really great if captain marvel just
bailed her out it's like listen she's
fine um
if you don't think if
you can fight me for it because like i'm
gonna take this girl now um but yeah i
know i love that i really love that idea
and i think that i i'm gonna award that
one my rogue rogueist rogue question the
answer of the day because i think that
would be really fun i just want to see i
want to see rhodey be the next like
coulson in all these series he's just
showing up like all right i'm here at
this shield ceremony and now i'm here
saving miss marvel and i'm flying around
being i don't know
war machine of peace meeting new friends
um but yes i think that's really fun but
all of these ideas are wonderful i love
you guys you guys are so smart and you
guys are the rogues people that i know
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory huge thank you to our guests
jessica clemons whitney van landingham
and eddie villenueva go support them
wherever they are especially go check
out the film lost the first podcast with
eddie villanueva really great guy and
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you have
some rogue theories of your own be sure
to join our new rockstars discord to
search for new rockstars over on discord
if you're 18 and older to join the
conversation today you can follow me at
masterchain on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] really fun
theories but most importantly you can
hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
video here on youtube after you
subscribe it's very important subscribe
first then hit the notification bell
that's in order to do these things all
right thank you guys so much for
watching we love you guys and we'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]